[Musique]
un contrôle routier à belfort en janvier
le lieutenant camille delonca et ses
hommes viennent tout juste de se poster
sur un des axes les plus dangereux de la
ville
magnifique
parfait
démonstration par l'absurde
superbe
on va bien
vous pouvez le contacter
c'est pas grave d'abord ne pas blesser
il n'y a pas de couleur
attendez madame madame s'il vous plaît
ne m'étais pas lasser dont je rejoue
c'est vous sur le côté alors oui mais
vous faites un constant parce que tout
le monde avait la ceinture personne
n'est blessé non non non pour un bien
j'ai
cinq ans
camille de l'oncad dirige la brigade
accidents de belfort depuis six ans
abc certainement alors ça c'est sans
vous dire mieux vous étiez prêts et
bourses est pareil ne quitteront pas
résultat des courses par bonheur
personnes et blessé mais imaginez là
c'est un choc avec une voiture arrêtée
une autre qui lui rentrer dedans mais
imaginez ça aurait pu être beaucoup plus
vite si vous respectez pas les distances
de sécurité vous avez vous eu lieu à 50
km/heure vous ne vous arrêterez pas ce
retrait mais dans la voiture de devant
en tout cas vous auriez tout votre
ceinture très bien
[Musique]
aujourd'hui le lieutenant camille
delonca occupe toujours le terrain ce
matin à belfort la neige rend la
circulation particulièrement difficiles
les dizaines de véhicules sont contrôlés
avec un seul mot d'ordre la tolérance
zéro bonjour police nationale je
demandais de vous mettre un peu sur la
droite la con libé à l'accès est ce que
vous avez vu là il ya une plaque
illisible avant il manque un numéro donc
pas je compterai de véhicules et puis je
dressais seulement une contravention en
fonction de ce que me dira la personne
même si il ne manque qu'un seul numéro
sur cette plaque les policiers sont
intraitables aujourd'hui on travaille à
l'heureux des radars automatiques
voilà vous passé au travers à chaque
fois ça vous fait flash flash et vous
manque un numéro un
quelque chose comme ça ça serait
peut-être passé quelques années encore
ce serait tout à fait passé mais c'est
vrai que maintenant laisse plus passer
parce que déjà on a reçu les
instructions pour ne rien laisser passer
mais on attendait que ce à quoi donc
maintenant effectivement ne laisse plus
rien passer
la conductrice devra payer 45 euros
avant trois jours
cette politique de tolérance zéro a
permis d'obtenir des résultats immédiats
sur belfort s'est
très nettement la vitesse qui a bien
diminué le nombre de morts qui
continuent à diminuer également
malheureusement le nombre de blessés ne
diminue pas aussi vite qu'on le
souhaiterait on espère simplement que on
va réussir à faire tourner la machine de
façon à ce qu'ils aient de moins en
moins de blessés sur la route et puis ça
va passer par une répression accrue
comme vous pouvez voir
en voyant les policiers un automobiliste
vient de prendre la fuite et s'est
engouffré dans une rue en sens interdit
[Musique]
les motards le prennent aussitôt en
chasse il a pris le sens interdit qui
est justement est ce qui fait que sont
allés le chercher là bas
d'où l'utilité d'un mouton avec une
voiture vous pouvez pas démarrer aussi
vite n'est pas assurée est ce que vous
êtes assurés avec nous vous êtes pas le
contrôle technique ne purent 50 depuis
quatre ans
sans jouer la carte de la tdlg vous avez
perdu voilà on nous prenait pour des
fous à ce fléau en garde à vue sans
maintenance et coordonnées si vous
continuez comme ça aucun jeu là vous
avez pris l'ascenseur du bon il ya un
défaut d'assurance défaut de contrôle
technique et puis on va essayer
directoire et ben on va aller faire un
petit tour au commissariat cher monsieur
vous avez quelqu'un qui peut vous
conduire un véhicule abeilles mais bien
de
quelqu'un pour récupérer votre frère
monsieur et votre enfant la mutation
peut voir la voiture s'il n'y a pas
d'assurance mais bien de venir les
chercher
c'est bien vos enfants vos enfants de
procès comme ça me sourit à monsieur
nous prenez pas pour des nuls à
l'habitude nous sommes sur des gens qui
font comme vous on a l'habitude vous
avez pas vu qu'on à droite parce qu'il y
avait du monde je pourrais pas me garder
de vous êtes vous monsieur mais comme
découlent au mieux mieux de la route 7
comme des cons
me souvenais 15h50 monsieur il est 15h
et j'en avais la food co va où je vous
placent en garde à vue après cette
annonce
alors ok et je vous retient loutre
ajoutant mais vous ne mettez les besoins
de son patron que le 2e tour vous mettez
le match on est en forme en se
maintenant ça commence à bien faire
savaria monsieur se sert à rien
djoudi et regardez derrière vous le
gamin qui vous regardent
vous mais qu'ils avaient tout pour toi
comme estime seuil alors que les
parkings les trois quarts d'heure qu'on
est là vous n'êtes pas le trône où je
n'accepte pas d'être pris en flagrant
délit ça les énerve
voit la suite ça s'énerve le tamoul et
nous permettent d'être constant il ya
des limites cela les dépasser donc je
vais retenir
outrages de défaut de contrôle technique
délit de fuite le sens interdit
et le dépôt d'assurance ont poliment que
rien quoi au total j'ai des fondations
d'accord la décoration on a une deuxième
voiture on a des structures ce qu'on a
quatre enfants chômage en ce moment la
voiture est en panne devant la maison
j'ai pris la deuxième
alors et alors c'est comment avoir un
accident maintenant avec votre voiture
sont rassurants ça donne quoi ça va
donner que vous allez payer avis c'est
pas il ne s'est pas une excuse suis
désolé c'est pas une excuse et de la
loutre est qu on fasse une vraie fan
mais pas non plus
on est là pour arrêter les gens qui vont
des conneries s'est désolé nous n'avait
il pas eu de dresser quatre mois ou 5 et
finir en nous insultant là c'est le
pompon
ce sont des assassins en puissance
des gens comme ça le véhicule ça fait
quatre ans que le contrôle technique n'a
pas été passée c'est à dire aucune idée
de l'état réel du véhicule c'est pas si
les freins sont en étant c'est pas si
les amortisseurs peuvent réagir c'est
pas tellement pour que les amortisseurs
réagissent mais au niveau de la sécurité
dans un virage à grande vitesse le rôle
de marty seraient vraiment y seraient
quand même très importants leur vin est
très important il a quatre enfants il
les met en danger il met sa propre
famille en danger dans un véhicule comme
ça sinon on fait pas quelque chose pour
les empêcher de se nuire même je ne sais
pas qui veulent faire il faut que
quelqu'un le fasse alors
si je baisse les bras ce changement
le père de famille est emmené au
commissariat pour être entendus par des
policiers
pour camille l'audition est une bonne
occasion de faire prendre conscience aux
conducteurs de son attitude alors c'est
ça va mieux oui mais
bon force n'est pas l'autre avion comme
je vous disais puisque vous êtes calmez
vous avait présenté des excuses moi pas
vous retenir votre âge
ça vous évite une garde à vue j'espère
que vous en être conscient vous aurez à
gérer comment vos cibles également
percuté ou renversés par quelqu'un qui
n'a pas de contrôle technique qui n'a
pas d'assurance qui n'a plus de points
sur son permis
[Musique]
certainement pas bien donc vous
comprenez que le prisme à réagir parce
qu'on voit ça souvent vous restez notre
homme se termine trop 3 et à vos
oreilles vous allez perdre les autres
différents de conneries stopper une
ceinture et l'excès de vitesse le coup
trois points coup
3.3.2 3.3.3
la suite et puis ça
c'est pas que je fasse un petit château
je crois que c'est pas la peine il
faudra carrément leur passé
huit mois en moins et un permis annulé
d'office dans quelques semaines l'homme
sera convoqué au tribunal
il risque trois mois de prison ferme et
jusqu'à 3 ans d'annulation de permis
pour camille la chasse aux chauffards
continue la semaine prochaine elle va
contrôler des cars scolaires près d'un
collège de belfort
un hélicoptère de la gendarmerie
nationale amiens
[Musique]
le major emile lavalard survol
l'autoroute du nord
au sol en liaison directe avec
l'hélicoptère une équipe du majeur à
bord d'une voiture d'intervention rapide
alors on va défendre après
asseyez on va deschamps l'appelle le
destrier jusqu'à faire demi-tour son
feuillage droit de passage sur les
perspectives pour remonter
fait nouveau l'hélicoptère d'abord conçu
pour détecter les grands excès de
vitesse sert aujourd'hui à repérer la
moindre infraction au code de la route
[Musique]
les bons plans un homme
permet un peu
non
de couleur à
une boule noire
parce que vous apporterez cercle
[Musique]
ouais c'est reçu la voiture repérée
roule en permanence sur la voie centrale
un comportement aujourd'hui sanctionner
les gendarmes se lancent aussitôt à sa
poursuite
notre quotidien c'est par cette
opération qu'on arrive à des idées des
comportements
le chant des pins qui te prêter bus la
circulation est complètement dégagé
il ne peut pas faire mal an la voie
centrale
[Musique]
la brigade d'intervention rapide escorte
la voiture interpellé jusqu'au prochain
péage ce sont les motards qui vont
prendre le relais et sanctionner le
conducteur
je lui dis
après ça
les gendarmes repart de traquer le
chauffard
quelques heures plus tard retour à la
gendarmerie
en un an le major lavalard et ses hommes
ont vu évoluer les comportements sur la
route
les points 2 sont tous les accidents
corporels de la circulation routière et
les points rouges ce sont les accidents
mortels on peut remarquer que les grands
axes routiers actuellement sont plus ou
moins délaissé par une certaine
délinquance routière et ils empruntent
les vous les axes en parallèle comment
vous l'expliquez ça les contrôles c'est
à dire que ont intensifié les contrôles
sur un réseau donné les usagers pour
éviter les contrôles se déplace et là
nous nous trouvons face à une
départementale où nous avons un accident
mortel en début de cette semaine et des
accidents sur vignacourt toute cette
partie malgré notre présence on
s'aperçoit que ça continue
alors pour être encore plus efficace les
gendarmes ont trouvé une nouvelle parade
cet après-midi le majeur la valeur
abandonne son uniforme pour aller sur le
budget de la gendarmerie louer une
voiture comme n'importe quel particulier
nous allons donc aller travailler sur le
terrain en civil avec un véhicule
banalisé c'est une autre manière le
traquer les chauffards
vous allez prendre un petit peu de
distance vous allez nous laisser un peu
de champ devant nous un ne pas rester
collés derrière la voiture vous allez
prendre un petit peu de champ derrière
derrière la voiture banalisée deux
motards en liaison directe avec le major
prête à intercepter les conducteurs
contrevenants c'est cette façon d'agir
qui nous permet de nous infiltrer dans
le flot de circulation avec un véhicule
banalisé sans qu'on soit repéré tout ce
qu on va constater remarqué relevé
téléphone portable franchissements de
lignes continues défaut de port de
ceinture
ce qu'on signale et est sanctionnée par
les motocyclistes
première interpellation quelques minutes
plus tard le berlingo qui a devant nous
le conducteur est au téléphone
ouais c'est celui là il est au téléphone
voilà
alors ça c'est une infraction vraiment
caractérisée comme on peut le voir
deux points en moins pour le conducteur
et une amende de 35 euros
au même moment une autre équipe du major
teste un nouveau dispositif un radar
automatique embarqué
au point de non retour en voiture voilà
les gens ne peuvent pas dire qu'on les
pièges c'est clair c'est s'est pas
dissipée et non seulement au bout de
ligne droite je sais pas combien de
mètres il peut y avoir mais suffisamment
pour qu'ils coupent la vitesse
donc vous avez un salut à votre place de
contrôles voilà exactement c'est mon
poste de contrôle exactement
alors la vitesse légale 90 donc la
vitesse à partir de laquelle les
vitesses enregistrées soit 96
90 à clichés la personne vient de passer
à 102 km heure au lieu des 90
réglementaires
un peu plus tard la voiture équipée du
radar embarqué se déplace à l'entrée
d'un tout petit village
et là vous fixer la limite de
déplacement à quelle vitesse 50cc pour
moi qui la fixer l'appareil
agglomération s'est limité à 50 le seuil
pour cet appareil c'est 56 y en a pas
d'autre il s'agit pas de le mettre à 75
je ne peux pas intervenir c'est 56
en tout 8
dès lors que quelqu'un passe à au moins
56 la photo est prise elle sera
exploitée donc là à deux kilomètres près
ils étaient sauves quoi bas 3 3 km à 3
km il passe à 55
il passe bien et passe à 56 et les pris
en photo
c'est dur quand même
en fait pour les textes en général cette
personne qui s'est fait prendre à 58
normalement à son compteur doit indiquer
entre 60 et 62
en général c'est comme ça les les
compteurs vitesse des véhicules sont un
peu plus haut forez que j'ai avec la
réalité
à quelques kilomètres de là le majeur
lavalard lui continue sa surveillance
banalisée
je vois pas la ceinture
vérifier un peu le camion gris qui
arrivent vers toi j'ai pas vu la
ceinture au chauffeur j'ai pas vu la
ceinture du chauffeur regarde le 19
tonnes tête cabine grisé et caisse
blanche on a un camion un 19 tonnes s'il
nous avait vus en tenue la rue des
appels de phare et il aurait porté la
ceinture donc ça évite et d'une halle à
l'appel de phare des autres usagers
signalant un poste de contrôle
deuxièmement on voit des des infractions
qu'on n'a pas l'habitude de voir puisque
on n'est pas décelée donc les gens ont
un comportement qu'ils ont
habituellement
c'est ça le but en fin de compte c'est
de trouver et de bannir le comportement
que chaque individu a dans son
comportement journalier on a tous des
défauts
mais c'est cela qu'on banni
et vous là les motards froment gonfla
vous avez des transports from en tenant
bon qui remonte sur amiens il est au
téléphone
là encore sous les ordres du major les
motards interpellent le conducteur
il ya un seul but à atteindre et le butô
c'est moins d'accidents moins
d'incivilités et - catastrophe sur les
routes alors pour les moyens sont bons
en fin de compte pour obtenir le but à
atteindre
demain c'est le début du week end alors
le majeur lavalard passera la nuit avec
ses hommes à surveiller les sorties de
discothèques c'est entre le vendredi et
le dimanche soir que la route fait le
plus de victimes notamment chez les
jeunes
cour d'appel de toulouse en février 2004
ce jour là jeanne collard défend la
famille d'un jeune homme tué par un
chauffard qui roulait avec plus de 3
grammes d'alcool dans le sang c'est pas
moi qui vais plus dire vous savez c'est
ma fille donc je suis là par solidarité
et pour pour un combat auquel je crois
plus que ma vie donc si on gagne pas
celui-là on en fera un autre d'accord
voilà ne sera jamais mort pour rien
un combat contre la violence routière
qu'elle partage depuis plus de deux ans
avec sa fille remy avocates comme elle
dans cette affaire elle espère obtenir
un jugement exemplaire
le chauffard est déjà dans la salle à
quelques mètres de la famille
regardez le quand vous lisez votre texte
la minière si vous avez le courage et la
france je crois que la dea droit dans
les yeux et vous vous adressez à lui
c'est bien me regardez pas ce que tu
manges
trois heures plus tard le verdict tombe
l'homme est condamné à un an de prison
ferme l'avocate est déçu pour jeanne
collard les délinquants de la route
mérite de lourdes peines de prison c'est
pour ça qu'elle se bat depuis 10 ans
c'est après un grave accident que jeanne
collard a fait le choix de se
spécialiser dans la défense des victimes
de la route
passagère d'une voiture qui s'est
encastrée dans un camion elle est resté
plus d'un mois dans le coma
j'ai perdu toute une partie masi en
termes de mémoire et ça c'est dur c'est
vrai ce que par exemple je rencontre une
amie d'enfance qui
qui se jettent un bon coup est
d'abord je la reconnais pas et ensuite
quand elle me parle de souvenirs communs
c'est comme si elle racontait une
histoire qui ait jamais existé pour moi
et
puis il n'y a pas que ça qui est dur de
toute façon à ce qui est dur c'est
souvent je souffre beaucoup et donc de
souffrir dans son corps de
être complètement différent quoi c'est
une autre vie
vous pensez que si vous avez pas été
touché par cet accident j'aurais pu
quand même rejoindre ce combat
non et attention j'ai honte de ce que je
vous dis
j'ai honte
parce que parce qu'en lisant ça je
ressemble à tous les français c'est à
dire je ne m'y intéresse que parce que
j'ai souffert
bon
un an après dans le sud de la france
jeanne collard poursuit son combat
ce matin elle vient rendre visite à
gaylord au centre de rééducation de
hendaye
depuis deux ans elle prépare le procès
avec les parents du jeune garçon
se réveille
c'est maître collard gay la stèle cette
défense gaylord avait décidé de fêter
noël avec ses copains en discothèque il
s'est fait faucher par une voiture alors
qu'il rentrait à pied sur une route
nationale
le conducteur n'a pas pris la peine de
s'arrêter aujourd'hui gaylord à 21 ans
il est dans ce que les médecins
appellent un coma végétatif
c'est capital d'abord pour eux mais ce
que
je considère comme des amis
ils savent c'est une histoire à trois
c'est pas
et oui c'est important mais en même
temps c'est c'est difficile c'est zéro
prise de karkwa c1
cette saloperie de ville cette saloperie
de banias
je suis folle envie de mourir je les uns
c'est clair il ya des moments où je vais
tout arrêter quoi mais j'ai pas le droit
je dis oui il se bat lui il faut que je
me batte aussi mais il ya des moments je
me dis c'est quoi cette vie
franchement aidé moment je veux pas me
laisser aller je m'habille jma qui tout
ça me tient parce que en rond avec
j'aime ça et que et je me dis pour
gaylord je veux qu'ils ferment on image
mais bon c'est vrai que c'est super dur
il ya des matins j'ai avec une chose que
je me refuse à faire on nous a dit
plusieurs fois c'est faire faire le
deuil d'un enfant vivant ça c'est une
parole que je ne peux pas c'est une
phrase que je peux pas
je peux pas emmagasiner que je peux pas
mettre dans ma tête on nous a dit de
faire le deuil de son enfant actuelle je
peux pas faire le deuil d'un enfant qui
vivent ça c'est une phrase que j'ai eu
beaucoup de mal à
votre enfant oui non message est bien
que vous la connais je n'ai bien compris
mais c'est quelque chose que j'ai du mal
à
mettre dans ma tête c'est clair ça c'est
depuis le début jeune je me refuse à ça
pour l'instant mais bon
je pense qu'on va rejoindre dans sa
chambre dur quoi ces secteurs du
ski retouchera c'est ce qui est quand il
fait on écoute des musiques quand il
faisait le clown dessus quand il
pleut ça me vient en tête j'essaie de
m'occuper d'aller faire autre chose vite
pour que sa part parce que je veux c'est
trop dur on parle beaucoup des deux
nombre de tués sur les routes qui
diminue on parle beaucoup moins des
blessés graves comme gaylord paris ça
c'est d'ailleurs pour moi je vais vous
dire c'est inadmissible et j'en ai marre
qu'on ne parle que des morts et pas des
blessés alors c'est vrai que pour qu'on
les oublie
je sais pas parce qu'on pense peut-être
que les morts sa frappe plus d'opinion
publique que les mamys et voilà
mais il faut on n'a pas le droit on n'a
pas le droit d'oublier tous les morts
vivants
que la route fait donc je pense que
c'est à nous c'est un ou deux de faire
passer ce message de dire de dire la
route elle tue et c'est insupportable
mais elle tue lui notre manière et elle
fait des morts-vivants et c'est aussi
insupportable et il n'y a pas de
différence voilà
à
le lendemain à paris
c'est jeanne collard et sa fille romy
qui assure la défense de monsieur et
madame guérin les parents de gaylord je
pense que aujourd'hui ils sont ensemble
pour préparer le procès
dire quelque chose
je pense qu'il ya des moments où il fera
ses biens je pense moi je pense ce qui
m'angoisse moi surtout aussi c'est sa
réaction c'est savoir comment il va
réagir il va falloir qu'ils soient
petits parce que s'ils commencent à
vouloir le prendre de haut je vais je
sais pas comment je vais gérer d'une
manière l'attitude que vous craignez pas
la boire monsieur bah je vois je pense
je crois qu'il va continuer à dire que
le match on pensait que c'était un
animal qui s'est arrêté qu'il a rien vu
donc c'est ça qui va être difficile à
entendre c'est malheureusement ce n'est
le discours qu'on entend
systématiquement il n'y a pas de témoin
donc
pourquoi une infraction pénale il faut
qu'il y ait une faute pénale dont
gaylord rentrer à pied sur une route non
éclairée bon et comme on sait pas
comment c'est passé l'accident gallant
pouvait être au milieu de la route
monsieur locale qu'un lot pouvais pas
l'éviter donc qu'il y ait eu une
ouverture de poursuites pour combler sur
un volontaire mais mais le parc avant
mais le juge d'instruction a rendu une
ordonnance de non lieu partiel voilà moi
si vous voulez ce que ce que parce que
j'ai envie de dire demain c'est que la
fuite je la condamne pas la fuite sur
sur 100 m je la prenais pas c'est la
peur j'ai peur
badri depuis mai on s'arrête on appelle
les secours en faire quelque chose on
n'est ce pas un enfant ne s'en laisse
pas un enfant dans le froid dans la pub
descendez pleut il a froid il s'en fout
il s'enfuit il veut sauver sa peau il
veut sauver sa peau c'est ça qui est
extrêmement grimpeuse est bien plus
grave que le délit en lui-même le d'élus
blessures involontaires bien plus grave
que ça c'est vu il ya un an pour une
autre affaire vous avez le sentiment
toutes les deux que les choses évoluent
quand même en que moi je pense que rien
n'a changé mais je pense qu'en
vieillissant je deviens extrémistes donc
c'est à dire que je voudrais toujours
que toujours plus voilà donc c'est quoi
toujours palpable c'est à dire moi je
dis les lois soient pas pourquoi
aujourd'hui un type qui tue sous
l'empiré d'un état alcoolique ses 10 ans
je vois pas pourquoi on donne pas dix
ans à ce mois qu'on m'explique et
circonstances des noms qu'on trouve à ce
type d'individu bon
mais mes romy vous dira qu'elles sont un
frémissement peut-être un léger
frémissement très léger frémissement
s'est il reste encore beaucoup de chemin
à parcourir je crois que les efforts
sont encore
très mince je crois que les magistrats
restent encore très frileux alors on a
de manière isolée une décision dont on
se félicite parce qu'effectivement c'est
une décision qui est sévère mais ça
reste encore beaucoup trop rare
aujourd'hui pour qu'on puisse dire que
les choses ont avancé dans la sphère
gaylord le conducteur est poursuivi pour
délit de fuite et non assistance à
personne en danger il risque jusqu'à
cinq ans de prison ferme et 50
d'annulation de pernod demain le procès
s'ouvre à orléans
avec vous dès maintenant c'est bien que
dans physiquement
[Musique]
l'hôpital necker à paris
c'est dans ce service de neurochirurgie
pédiatrique qu'arrive la plupart des
enfants accidentés de la route philippe
meyer est anesthésiste réanimateur et ce
matin il rend visite à blandine arrivé
la veille
la petite fille est encore dans le coma
mais ses jours ne sont pas en danger on
a allumé un peu la lumière
bon elle veut ouvert un oeil quand même
oui
il faut
landina 9 ans elle a eu un accident à la
sortie de son école elle s'est fait
percuter par une voiture alors qu'elle
traversait sur un passage clouté landina
la joue
pour ces traversées on sait faire
attention
et
où malheureusement on est un petit peu
dépendant aussi de l'environnement alors
même si on traverse au bon endroit
qu'on fait attention
on peut se retrouver face à une voiture
qui elle ne fait pas attention ou qui va
trop vite mais ça représente un choc
important
on peut imaginer une
enfant de neuf ans face à mike tyson
s'est un petit peu la même chose
donc qu'elle a elle a un traumatisme
crânien qui ne s'est pas traduit par une
lésion au niveau de son cerveau ce qui
est très bien mais elle reste quand même
largement dormi et puis on va la
surveiller encore pendant 24 48 heures
pour être sûr qu'il n'y a pas de
problème particulier en principe les
choses devraient se passer très très
simplement ensuite
[Musique]
qui est le coupable
l'enfant le conducteur ou la voirie
chercher
zones accidentogènes y avait déjà eu des
accidents oui oui
à mon ma connaissance il ya ma première
fille déjà en janvier 2000 il ya une
enfant qui a eu un accident il ya quinze
jours de ça et puis ma fille aujourd'hui
toujours un endroit pratiquement là où
elle l'a traversée blandine il n'y a pas
de feu il ya le passage piéton est là où
on traverse et des deux autres enfants
il ya des feux mais bon les feux sont
pas toujours respectées par les camps
les conducteurs malheureusement c'est un
cas classique
on serait presque
tenté de dire banale s'est jamais banal
parce qu'il faut pas se dire qu'un
accident ses bananes mais c'est un cas
classique chaque année un tiers des
enfants qui ont un traumatisme grave
sont renversés par une voiture et a dit
qu'elle va bien ouais mais ça en prend
une fois qu'elle sera sortie de
l'hôpital
j'ai l'habitude faut bien compter 48
heures pour pour être sûr que qui a pas
de problème particulier
des enfants comme blandine dans ce
service de réanimation il en arrive
toujours autant environ 300 par an
malgré une baisse importante des blessés
de la route ici on est loin d'être
optimiste en ce qui concerne les
passagers des véhicules
on a une diminution très importante du
nombre de traumatismes graves parce que
les enfants sont plus en plus saturés
ont de plus en plus des sièges adaptés à
leur poids etc mais par contre quand on
regarde les piétons renversés
ça change pas
et cette année on n'a pas vu de
diminution
il ya quelques jours on a en a même eu
un gamin qui a été renversé par une
voiture en ville et qui est mort parce
que la voiture lui a roulé dessus parce
qu'elle a pas eu le temps de freiner il
avait 4 ans
on a vu en une semaine quatre piétons
renversés alors mon bonhomme 1,1 du dos
caron qu'a fait partie des quatre
enfants renverser cette semaine il a de
multiples fractures du crâne n'est
heureusement pas de lésions au cerveau
est ce que tu veux bien t'asseoir hop tu
me montres comme tu tiens qui lui aussi
a été renversé en pleine ville lui aussi
à la sortie de l'école alors une chose
extrêmement simple à faire c'est de
faire de façon drastique
devant toute sortie d'école un système
qui permettent de rouler au maximum à 30
km heure sinon on perd ses deux roues
avant c'est la seule solution ça peut
pas se faire en une année c'est bien
évident ce qui nous agace beaucoup plus
et le comportement irresponsable des
gens qui ont ces ralentisseurs qui ont
une zone à 30 qui roule à 80 avec un
gros 4 4 qui lui passe sans aucun
problème sur un ralentisseur oui cela
c'est nous agace beaucoup et c'est cela
en général qui sont responsables
d'accidents un petit gamin comme celui
ci le pare chocs d'un 4 4 est exactement
à la hauteur de sa tête sont pas des
délinquants primaires sont des gens qui
n'ont aucune notion
qui n'ont aucun respect aussi des autres
la plupart du temps et ça c'est très
très agaçant
bourbon sont encore un peu la tête hein
ce normal bon à tout à l'heure bonhomme
un peu la tête là
[Musique]
deux jours plus tard
le monde regarde l'extérieur
soit il va y aller un lord henin dans la
chambre de blandine c'est le soulagement
la petite fille a totalement récupéré à
l'exception de quelques bleus par contre
il faut pas que tu leur as toi parce que
si tu grattes ça nous fait une petite
cicatrice ça va disparaître plus
doucement
birsa reconnaître qu'elle est
miraculeuse quoi quelque part ça vous
allez mettre quelques jours vous
convaincre que que tout va bien mais
c'est normal sourire
mais les larmes sont pas loin derrière
non plus encore oui mais cette foutue ce
plus de larmes de joie le sang à l'eba
c'est bien on préfère quand même les
voir rester peu de temps et et sortir
vite que le voir des soucis ensuite bon
tu viens pas un trop mauvais souvenir de
nous
aurait préféré ne pas venir nous voir ça
c'est sûr non c'est très bien parce que
elle n'aura probablement absolument
aucune séquelle de cet accident donc
c'est parfait ouais ils vous ont pas
encore demandé de servir
[Musique]
à belfort justement le lieutenant
camille delonca intensifient les
contrôles à la sortie des écoles ce
matin elle s'intéresse plus
particulièrement aux transports
scolaires les bus et les cars depuis
quelques mois sont devenus des cibles
privilégiées pour les forces de l'ordre
bonjour tout le monde va essayer 30
secondes s'il vous plaît non je suis
arrivé j'en ai vu pas mal qui était
debout dans le bus
un alors un coup de froid vous retrouver
tous devant à plat ventre vous devez
rester assis dans le bus jusqu'à ce que
le bus s'arrête d'accord alors vous êtes
prudent avec ça et vous faites attention
restez assis jusqu'à ce qu'elle s'arrête
vous descendrez pas pluie tombait
porteront pas ouvert toute façon la
législation mise en place pour les
transports scolaires est très stricte
effectué plusieurs fois par mois ce type
de contrôle ne laisse rien passer
le pictogramme c'est le panneau qui
signale le transport d'enfants il doit
être visible à l'avant et à l'arrière du
véhicule
mais là début cela c'est un peu une
nouveauté ça non il ya un an il ya deux
ans faisait pas tout ça c'est vraiment
le fasse et pas et ça va toujours dans
le sens de plus de sécurité puisque
maintenant les bus sont même équipés de
ceintures de sécurité c'est-à-dire les
bus qui sont construits depuis 1999 sont
équipés de ceintures de sécurité et
normalement toute personne qui monte
dans le bus équipés de ceintures est
tenu de mettre sa ceinture de sécurité
alors non
pour le moment on incite vivement les
gens à le faire on est encore dans la
période prévention information
avertissements arrivera un jour on ne
sera dans la période de répression
également montfa leur nom n'est pas la
même à l'heure du petit déjeuner les
policiers effectuent des contrôles
d'alcoolémie
l'expérience leur a prouvé que c'était
nécessaire
une conductrice de bus qui transportait
38 enfants a été
contrôlé positif à l'éthylotest est
largement positif à l'éthylomètre donc
elle avait deux grammes et quelques je
crois dans le sang évidemment on
arrêtait tout de suite le bus passe
était pas nous mêler les collègues qui
s'en sont occupé le bus a été arrêté la
dame a été placée en garde à vue et mon
tout ce qui va avec mais bon
c'est quand même grave de conduire un
bus d'une poche remplie d'un flan
d'autre part en ayant bu de l'alcool
c'est bon
[Musique]
0 c'est parfait avec
aucun problème pour ce chauffeur
il est 8h30 les élèves entre collège
camille delonca elle poursuit les
contrôles à l'autre bout de la ville en
plein milieu de la zone industrielle
l'objectif de ce matin c'est les camions
et les camionnettes tous dès qu'il
appuie sur ses feux stop pour voir la
scène
non aucun feu stop
lui qui met sept minutes un pouvoir
et à droite
cette nuit la neige est tombée et la
route est particulièrement glissante
plus de stop
alors les policiers vérifient les
éclairages mais aussi les pneus
ceux là sont à la limite de la rupture
c'est pas le top là au caf top pour les
gens qui vous suivent c'est hyper
dangereux à temps et monsieur ça marche
et vous êtes vous avez vu l'état de
votre éclairage
a été cassé tout est cassé
on a parlé de l'arrière au niveau
éclairage et avant vous avez vu un à
droite
cassée on est bon c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui ça bon vous allez me
suivent au véhicule de police en plus de
la mangue le conducteur devra remettre
en état son véhicule moi vous à vous
présenter il y aura des feux qui seront
neuf à l'arrière c'est pas un mais deux
ampoules et puis ça marche un coup c'est
mon choix avait 48 heures pour le faire
et nous présenter le camion demi en état
passé ce délai on pourra mettre le
camion jour hier
le conducteur n'en est pas à sa première
infraction et son permis de conduire a
déjà été annulés une fois maintenant se
retrouver
avec les remises non avec eux le code de
la route il y a toujours la vitesse vous
avez vous lu vite oui
pourquoi
parce que j'ai des voitures qui sont
relativement puissantes et puis on cette
attention
la vitesse on le sait très bien elle
n'est pas beau n'est pas très très bonne
personne est suffisamment bon conducteur
pour faire de la vitesse on va sur un
circuit on va pas sur la route moi je
dit sur une autoroute c'est pas grave
c'est mon point de vue c'est vrai que la
loi il faut pas ses 131
j'hallucine comme quoi dans je récupère
la carte est prise
[Musique]
18 heures pour camille la journée n'est
pas terminée hier à belfort en voulant
éviter un contrôle de police un jeune
homme de 20 ans qui roulait sans permis
a percuté deux voitures c'est le
lieutenant delonca qui est chargée de
l'enquêté aux policiers ont
immédiatement interpellé l'automobiliste
qui a expliqué avoir fui le contrôle
carnets sous le coup d'une suspension de
permis de trois mois je vais aller voir
la victime qui va me raconter elle même
ce qui s'est passé
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur comment allez vous ah
ça oui
c'est terrible ça et quatre
jambes sont pas
écoutés si vous permettez envolée
pardon des mois 2 vous avez mal partout
ça touche et les cervicales et les
décotes aussi alors chaque mouvement et
le pied cassé
le pied cassé aussi j'aime plâtre et le
bon le poignet qui soumet le saas est
aussi et qu'est ce qui s'est passé alors
motiver nos amis et et d'un coup j'ai vu
cette foutue blanche acquis qui arrivent
et les sharks qu'est ce qu'il fait là
c'est oui mais jean après j'ai entendu
le boom des premières voitures et
gym et continue après ben
qu'est ce qui s'est passé après vous
souvenez
je sais comme femmes à marier mois tous
les ans on faisait les eaux de bruit
parce qu'on n'arrive pas à respirer
c'est ce
baiser les grognements c'était très
étrange on n'arrivait pas respirer tout
de suite les deux et on était tous les
deux un
récit de son coupé comme moi vous êtes
de nationalité australienne est ce que
en australie c'est la même chose
l'australie a quand même comme on dit ça
les chefs à la papa est le plus bas dans
le monde pour les accidents les les
les règles enfin les lois sont beaucoup
plus strictes en australie je ne veux
pas forcer la france mais c'est vrai
le dégoût d'alcool pour les moins de 21
ans 6-0 et pour les chauffeurs c'est
zéro et il ya énormément de contrôler
les vitesses sont plus limités ici aussi
déjà ça vous étonne non
annonce a commencé trop laxiste encore
disons que si on commençait simplement
par appliquer les lois en vigueur ne
serait-ce que ça déjà les appliquer
consciencieusement
jusqu'au bout et pour tout le monde
ce serait déjà pas mal
après avoir pris la déposition de la
victime camille delonca est de retour au
commissariat elle va entendre le jeune
conducteur sans permis depuis l'accident
il a été placé en garde à vue
mettez vos chaussures et venez avec moi
allez on y va
je reconnais je suis entièrement tort et
si je peux m'excuser ou ne serait ce que
pour asseoir un peu plus heureuse au
radis fransat est soulagé qu'on ait pu
soulager dans sa tête moi je ferais
n'importe quoi ça c'est clair est ce que
maintenant vous allez recommencer à
conduire comme ça sans permis notre avis
c'est une connerie hausse trop grosse
connerie mais maintenant c'est
finalement peut-être l'âge d'or de
prison mais j'ai que la prochaine fois
si
la cabane directement
aïe certaines petites conneries comme ça
dure une semaine puis hop sourire
l'homme risque jusqu'à un an de prison
ferme et 15000 euros d'amendé
en un an le nombre de conducteurs
verbalisés pour conduite sans permis a
plus que doublé et ne cesse d'augmenter
un fleury mérogis en banlieue parisienne
un détenu sur dix est un délinquant de
la route pour la première fois à la
demande de l'administration
pénitentiaire l'association laser
spécialistes de la prévention routière y
mène une opération pilote donc aux dites
vous a déjà présenté un petit peu les
trois jours c'est david joue cinq qui
accueille les détenus donc moi je fais
partie de laser laser c'est d'actions de
sécurité routière d'accord on commence
avec cette matinée parce que je vais
appeler de la sensibilisation on va pas
dire qu'on va faire de la prévention
parce que là c'est malheureusement un
peu tard mais j'imagine que vous avez
tous
regardé les vues à la télé des spots de
sécurité routière donc qu'est-ce qui
fait que ça vous a pas touché est-ce que
ce que je vous présente vous touche
d'accord c'est ça qui m'intéresse pour
être sûr que peut-être chez vous ça
puisse déclencher quelque chose et vous
comprenez bien éventuellement ce qui
n'était pas le cas avant et puis d'avoir
ainsi votre sens critique meilleur
franchement ça me parle pas si
éventuellement vous êtes d'accord on
peut aussi se présenter juste votre près
d'une dizaine de prisonniers ont accepté
volontairement de participer à cette
journée
je suis ici pour avoir connu quelques
d'abord c'est pour l'alcool au volant
d'accord
pour dire que
tous sont récidivistes ils ont été
condamnés à des peines allant de deux
mois à deux ans de prison ferme
premier spot de la journée sur les
jeunes et l'alcool
0e on va papa c'est qu'il ya quelqu'un à
débouler directement comme ça
moi je bois je suis dans par exemple
chez dans le délire h et en voiture j'ai
envie d'écouter de la musique et voilà
c'est à dire je vais pas me dire dans ma
tétouan y ait quelqu'un qui va passer
vous à quelqu'un donc la question c'est
pourquoi la récidive et pourquoi même
quand on a l'info
on prend le risque alors il ya le côté
plaisir et puis à nous de leur faire
comprendre que au bout du plaisir il
peut y avoir ou la mort ou la paraplégie
ou
de la réfléchir d'autant que les sous
et voilà ça m'a un peu choqué ouais vous
avez une petite fille non non
qu'est ce qui pourrait déclencher chez
vous quelque chose qui modifierait votre
comportement
ainsi vos comportements l'échangé parce
qu'avant je m'étais prendre une fois
avec la colle au volant wii depuis ce
temps l'agent du vécu je conduisais mais
ce dom cole a pas permis
et ce en plus de leur peine de prison
ces détenus ont tous eu une annulation
de permis de conduire alors à fleury
c'est l'heure de tester sa vue et ses
réflexes pour se préparer à repasser un
jour l'examen de conduite pour d'autres
c'est même une première aymeric à 20 ans
il a toujours conduit sans permis
jeannot prod les risques
quand tu n'es pas les premières sera pas
le dernier jeu constant
permis d'être onéreux c'est pourquoi
parce que c'est dur parce que posent
beaucoup de questions qui sont durs à
comprendre qu'ils puissent qui ont
plusieurs réponses parce que quand il
pose une question il doit avoir arrêté
je sais pas peut-être deux trois
réponses
mais pas à 100 c'est tout c'est savoir
que
en plus le livre tu continues à cépet
donc ça prend un c'est de temps après
pour ça qu'elle est joli prénom ne vois
tu avais je dois prendre nos cordes à
vent
dans le groupe 2 générations les plus
âgées eux ont bien passé leur permis
mais ils l'ont perdue il ya bien
longtemps
arsène à 50 ans il est entrepreneur à 90
km heure on may 11 mai et à 130 km h sur
autoroute alors 16 m
c'est déjà pas mal ça fait sept ans que
j'ai mon permis enfin je les paie
maintenant à
tirer
je suis ainsi parce que j'ai été
contrôlé sans accident là sans rien
juste à contrôler fait que zéro gramme
ce sont bien les alcools
c'est moi beaucoup mais c'est assez pour
certains
j'ai eu huit mois de retrait de permis
et par rapport à mon travail lâcher
quand il a roulé de l'amour prénom sur
un peu prône toujours sont rapidement
sont d'accord ils m'ont hué permis
et j'ai la tête dure et j'écoute voit on
est quand même parce que je suis un
entrepreneur
j'ai pas le gros chômage ma femme
travaille pas si j'ai plus de voiture je
savais que jean que tout le monde à la
maison prg plus rien
durant cette séance vidéo sont des
images donc comme vous l'avez vu au
début tourné par les sapeurs-pompiers de
corbeil essonnes donc que des images
réelles d'intervention sur l'autoroute
notamment l'autoroute a6 d'accident mais
là on est plus dans la fiction
[Musique]
point fort de la journée les délinquants
de la route sont confrontés à des images
volontairement choquant
[Musique]
il
fait mal au coeur ce que c'est dur en
avoir mais c'est mieux de voir des
choses devraient plutôt que des choses
inventées ouais mais là funcom qui est
des gens qui essaient accident là il
pour lapointe pour certains qui est qui
mais celui-ci si on veut su si on veut
qu'ils aient moins d'accidents je pense
que ça ça ça va faire réagir les gens
combien de temps vont penser que ça peut
aussi vous restez en mémoire on voit
quelque chose à faire attention puis
après on peut oublier des fois ça va
nous rester mais
parallèlement je sais pas il faudrait le
répéter ça pourrait me ouvriers ont mal
réagi cité successivement vigilance on
essaye de voir ce qu'on peut faire parce
que malgré tout il n'est jamais trop
tard c'était déjà des récidivistes la
plupart il faut pas qu'il recommence
encore après il faut que ce passage ici
en prison soit utile qu'ils en retirent
quelque chose de plus c'est ce qu'on
nous demande de faire c'est pour ça que
nous sommes présents ici donc qu'ils en
retiennent quelque chose de plus et si
quelque part la prison sur les grandir
ce sera pas mal cette journée est une
première en france impossible encore
d'en connaître l'impact la semaine
prochaine c'est un tout autre combat que
vous menez david joussain cette fois
auprès des motards
[Musique]
10h du matin sur l'autoroute du sud
remis de la fille de maître collard
prend la relève de sa mère aujourd'hui
c'est le jour du procès du jeune gaylord
fauché par un conducteur qui a pris la
fuite à quelques heures avant un procès
dans quel état vous êtes je passerai
suspensives je suis conscient et je suis
douloureuse
parce que parce que je repense balle en
l'occurrence à agay lors je le vois sur
cette route je repense à chacun des
clients pour lesquels j'interviens et
je me mets à leur place donc
automatiquement je suis je suis pas en
s'immergeant but d'attirer l'attention
des magistrats sur sur ce comportement
abject cet homme qui va fuir qui va nier
ses responsabilités donc j'ai envie de
leur dire attention attention parce que
la personne que vous jugez aujourd'hui
c'est pas simplement un délinquant de la
route c'est quelqu'un qui nie
complètement sa responsabilité c'est
quelqu'un qui va être capable demain de
recommencer baisser encore un peu jeunes
sur la route donc j'ai envie de les
mettre en garde
l'instinct message ce message là que
j'ai envie de leur faire passer vous
baissez jamais les bras après les
décisions de justice sociale du tribunal
aussi si parce que céder parce que c'est
des audiences qu'on vit pleinement parce
qu'on s'investit on s'investit
intensivement et que on
cette décision là on a envie qu'elle
soit qu'elles soient toujours symbolique
qu'elle soit toujours sévère
au palais de justice d'orléans remis à
rendez-vous avec les parents de gaylord
quelques minutes avant l'audience elle
les prépare au face à face avec le
conducteur qui a renversé leur fils vous
savez ce que vous faites en prenez une
contre vous c'est que vous préférez vous
la tenez
c'était aussi
nous allons j'avais
pas très bien
très très bien plus on approchait dans
le temps que l'on arrivait dans ce
palais
c'est l'angoissé
vous suit
vous ne visualiser pas du tout non on
s'est posé la question en arrivant chien
ensemble
voilà ce procès aujourd'hui
pas grand chose
une partie qui s'arrêtent wacken
le groupe
c'est vraiment vous êtes une famille
c'est vrai qu'ils prennent conscience à
lui sa vie même s'il a une peine
il va la faire et après le temps où il
oubliera et de revivre il aura des
enfants il aura sa vie quoi nous c'est
fini
même si gaylord est là
que la physique ou
nous ne sommes pas autorisés à entrer le
conducteur lui est déjà dans la salle
pour la première fois la maman de
gaylord prend la parole devant l'homme
qui a fait basculer la vie de son fils
voit on pense qu'il comprend ce qu'on
dit on pense qu'il nous reconnaît il
entend ça c'est certain ça fait deux ans
qu'ils mangent pas ça fait deux ans
qu'ils parlent pas ça fait deux ans qu
il est là et il n'est pas décédé mais il
est plus quoi on a toujours espoir on a
toujours les parents ont dit et quand on
voit une petite chose quoi
c'est gagner mais pour les médecins nous
disent qu'on vous a pas caché qu'il
avait de très graves séquelles ne
parlera plus jamais il est tétraplégique
voilà
je comprends qu'on peut paniquer mais
moi ça peut m'arriver je peu paniqué
mais on s'arrête on a tous des portables
de dire que ça capte pas c'est vrai que
ce délit de fuite je me dis
si la vc la vue des soins plus
rapidement s'il avait été oxygéné plus
rapidement s'il avait son cerveau peut
être y aurait moins de séquelles il y
aurait peut-être trouvé quelque chose
l'audience a duré plus de deux heures à
la sortie la famille est assommé choqué
par le comportement du conducteur
c'est
celle au camp
se retenir
vous avez réussi à
maintenir ses décisions alors que nous
on avait des faits qu'ils sont quand
même flagrant on distille j'étais un
animal à l'image de m 84 enfin tout ce
qui s'en suit pas et qu'ils sucent se
confondent en d1 préhension dans les
désaccords et contradictions
il se contredit santoro lui pose la
question les moins capables de répondre
à la question où il est juste prix tout
à fait à ma place
c'est un supporter le hamas portait ses
propos et le fait de l'avoir vu moi qui
vois que j'étais indifférent j'ai pas vu
le voir en allant chercher un
magistrat était peu frileux on pourra
voir le présent faire deviner c'est
comme celui là et je crois cela d'autant
plus que l'attitude qui nous a montré ce
soir c'est vraiment ça ça nous fait avec
le doigt sur ce comportement qui laisse
sans voix qui laisse sans voix tu
laisses ont
cessé le supporter c'est insupportable
trois semaines plus tard nouvelle
déception pour la famille dans ce
dossier pas de surprise comme beaucoup
de délinquants de la route
le prévenu n'aura pas de prison ferme le
président a tranché 12 mois avec sursis
[Musique]
hôpital necker en novembre 2003 ce
jour-là adrien arrive en urgence après
avoir été percuté par un conducteur sans
permis à la sortie de son école
son meilleur ami est mort sur le coup
adrien lui est dans le coma et souffre
d'un grave traumatisme crânien
[Musique]
ces deux docteurs philippe meyer qui le
prend en charge dès son arrivée
les parents d'adrien sont les seuls
autorisés à voir leur fils en
réanimation
qui dynamise oui j'ai entendu
l'hélicoptère
[Musique]
et j'ai pensé qu'il y avait quelque
chose de grave commenté
commissariat mari
pour m'expliquer l'accédant
jacouton m'a dit qu'elle avait été
emmenée en alliés en hélicoptère
c'était la panique quoi ce matin là en
plus j'avais plein de gros gars je les
ai appelé juste avant de partir faites
attention aux voitures
parce qu'il vous voyais pas
arriver l'après midi en plein soleil
l'accident d'adrien fait les gros titres
des journaux dans la salle d'à côté les
infirmières sont en colère peut pas
mettre un flic à chaque carrefour c'est
évident mais moi je trouve que cette
histoire de répression et ben c'est une
bonne chose c'est tout ça de vrai e
devrait même s'accentuer aller plus loin
de ça on devrait police et amor rme
réprimée à mort tous ces chauffards
personnellement comme aux états unis tu
dépasses de 30 km/heure t arrêté dans
les taux en fils à une amende sophie
chef à kirby lapidation sont donc
[Musique]
devrait pas jamais lagoy
après cinq semaines d'hospitalisation
adrien présente enfin les premiers
signes de réveil
salut adrien le jeune garçon respire
seul et sans assistance d'un petit peton
mieux nous là
là il est
shampouiner brossé un bilan ça a déjà
repoussé d'ailleurs
mais impossible encore de se prononcer
sur son avenir
au bout d'un certain temps on a la
surprise de voir des enfants qui ont
remarquablement bien récupérer un
certain nombre de fonctions on ne
récupère jamais les enfants
qu'on avait avant le traumatisme ça
c'est parfaitement clair il reste
toujours un handicap qui est plus ou
moins important ce qu'on espère c'est
que ce handicap va être le moins
important pour ces possibles pour adrien
qui ça va lui permettre d'envisager une
une vie par la suite
[Musique]
voilà six mois qu adrien a quitté
l'hôpital necker
cet après midi philippe meyer va lui
rendre visite pour la première fois
depuis sa sortie ben vous tomber un
régime bruno yvelines vous avez une
tâche prioritaire
signer la carte pour adrien ça c'est
fait
je te dirai ça demain
les prendrai mais anne m'a dit que
n'avait bien progresser encore depuis
son départ adrien et dans un centre de
rééducation spécialisé
parce que c'est mon garçon est né le 12
février comme moi
adrien est resté quatre mois ici il a
marqué tous les esprits
et bien sûr chacun veut mettre un mot
sur la carte que philippe meyer a
préparé pour son anniversaire
ce qui nous a marqué particulièrement
c'est la force de caractère de
adrien puis de l'ensemble de sa famille
qui a vraiment lutter tous les instants
pour
pour le sortir de là
hôpital saint maurice en banlieue
parisienne
c'est dans ce centre de rééducation
qu'adrien a été pris en charge après sa
sortie de l'hôpital necker ici on
réapprend à vivre aux enfants victimes
de graves accidents de la route
[Musique]
adrien a maintenant 14 ans et depuis sa
sortie de l'hôpital il tente lentement
de se reconstruire
alors adrien
comment vas tu viens ya bien dit l'oim
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait on serre la
main on se fait une bise
j'ai encore le droit de te faire une
niche crois
parce que tu sais moi je t'apporte la
bise de plein de gens
que tu veux qu'on aille dans ta chambre
c'est comme tu veux
abadie dont rolala alors c'est nous un
virage
oui
et alors après tu fais quoi tu de gars
tu fais un créneau
alors s'il quel ton lit c'est celui où
il ya le plus de peluches à tien j'en
étais sûr et alors là tu vois il y a des
gens
pensez un peu à toi
hélas il y à
moi à moi je te dis tu vois que tous les
gars super nes le 12 février la preuve
moi je suis né le 12 février
rappelle de l'hôpital necker
sous rien
concernant
la wii and we only way est drôlement
bien de rien
en plus il a une aspirine au conseil
interrompue mais un peu parce que
c'était un petit peu on était un peu
maigrichon 1 quand tu es parti de chez
nous et puis il y est fait d'énormes
progrès et puis tu montreras tout à
l'heure comment tu
comment tu sors de ton fauteuil
super des
pierres
pour tous les enfants ici réapprendre à
marcher est une priorité adrien fait
chaque jour un peu plus de progrès
depuis un mois il a même fait ses
premiers pas ou peu montrées
tu me montres en a que nous montre un
soap des cartes des trucs ah ben tu le
fais toi même
[Musique]
au cas où
wadih dont
super
à lennon et du fun vous faire doucement
alors tu fais ça depuis combien de temps
ça fait combien de temps tu arrives à te
lever comme ça
et pas que tu veux tu rasseoir dit non
c'est super une photo d'adrien debout ça
ça ça leur ferait plaisir
c'est bien je vous impressionne
oui ça me oui oui ça m'a presque atteint
parce que ça représente un sacré effort
que tu fais ça
ainsi toi qui a fait les efforts pour
pour arriver à ça c'est drôlement bien
il n'y a pas que toi aussi tu as ma
manque beaucoup d'efforts pour que tu
arrives à ça aussi puis tous les gens
qui sont ici
[Musique]
bas et nous on a fait des efforts les
bulles
mais après c'est toi qui a fait plein de
choses pour en arriver là c'est bien
faut continuer
ou s'auto pour l'intention pas continuer
de toute façon
bon salut mon grand
la lui écoute pour tu parles attend à
waimes les
mais
même là ils n'auront non c'est toi qui
t'es sauvé la vie tous ces
des enfants accidentés de la route il y
en a malheureusement beaucoup dans ce
centre
ashley à 14 ans le même âge quadrille
il y a 6 mois elle ne prononcer que
quelques mots et elle était comme lui en
fauteuil roulant
aujourd'hui elle découvre l'escaladé ça
encore un peu voilà voilà postaux pied
par ashley a été renversé par une
voiture depuis elle tente d'oublier
l'accident est de dépasser ses angoisses
mais il est encore fragile et un simple
exercice peu vite la déstabiliser
cette recherche de thiérache l'inquiète
pas
ok on y va attention prudence ses deux
jambes la écarte attend ça c'est le pied
de elodie
équipe à celle de décembre même si un
jour tu vas le faire
et maintenant c'est bon le plus dur est
fait
et ça y est tu peux descendre call
aventure
où
ça a été tu l'as fait quand même
difficile
j'ai peur d'un deuxième accident
j'ai peur de tomber
le cadrage jeune âge et tu veux te voir
un petit peu
ouais bah si tu pouvais pas tomber là on
était là il y avait les tapis au début
il arrive souvent raison d'aidés
des troubles moteurs il n'arrive pas à
marcher puisque c'est la chose en
général qui récupère en premier et
ensuite il ya tous les troubles
cognitifs et ça ça se voit pas ça se
voit pas et donc c'est vrai que souvent
on voit des des enfants qui ont l'air
d'aller bien au delà mais pourquoi ils
sont ici c'est curieux et puis après il
ya d'autres troubles
effectivement qui sont rééduquer ici
dans sa langue aux thérapies aux
entretiens avec les psychologues les
neuropsychologues et tout ça et c'est ce
qu'on appelle lundi le handicap
invisible
et voilà donc souvent ça se voit pas
mais ça laisse des traces ça apporte des
difficultés pour la
réinsertion des enfants ensuite pour
trouver un milieu scolaire adapté ou non
à ces enfants là parce que c'est vrai
quand on va marcher on n'imagine pas
tout ce qui peut y avoir derrière et toi
alors prudence a fait des progrès depuis
que là depuis trois mois c'est ça je
crois moi moi mais raconte nous un peu
qu'est ce que tu as vécu trois ans j'ai
appris un marché
avec au fauteuil
la tenait juste derrière et je marche et
ça m'énerve quand les amis mon âge les
adolescents mon âge mes amis à moi ils
font des trucs qui s'amuse bien alors
que moi je suis un hôpital ça m'énerve
beaucoup
mois début j'ai cru que si je serai
marché je serai parler on laisserait
retourner chez moi mais c'est pas le cas
c'est vrai qu'au début elle marchait pas
et maintenant elle marche de mieux en
mieux elle fait même partie des rares ou
peu denses et puis on voit qu'elle se
débrouille bien sûr le mur d escalade en
plus ils sont tous ensemble ils se
voient marcher les uns et les autres ils
ont envie de de marché d'être comme il
était avant avant l'accident c'est vrai
que ils sont impatients et souvent nous
on est obligé de les freiner parce que
et n'ont pas suffisamment de contrôle
d'un point de vue moteur pour marcher
donc ils peuvent se blesser donc ça que
parfois on est obligé de les freiner ça
c'est un peu difficile de leur faire
comprendre que pour l'heure bien il faut
qu'il reste encore dans le fauteuil ou
qui portent des attelles etc
au revoir au revoir
dans les couloirs certaines rencontres
sont parfois douloureuses
ça te fait souffrir de voir d'autres
enfants blessés accidenté suite un
accident de la route comme tout louis
gagnon mais qui peuvent même pas qu'ils
sont chaise roulante qui vous restent en
chat trouveront toute leur vie ils
restent en chaise roulante toute leur
vie ils sont déformés du visage
tout ça ça te fait la peine
mehdi mais
cette femme elle a un coeur on dirait la
pâte coeur je me demande on dirait la
pâte coeur quelle femme la dame qui m'a
accident l'a renversé parce que
en fait elle elle m'a mes copains me
disent qu'elle m'a renversé et es10 est
dit ouais je peux rentrer chez moi
maintenant
sans avoir vu son nom être inquiète je
comprends pas les gens comme ça je
comprends pas chaud pas les comprends tu
en veux
permet je pense même que cela
et la souffrance se perd la partage avec
ashley anne sophie et son petit frère
était passager arrière d'une voiture qui
s'est fait percuté en pleine nuit par un
chauffard qui avait bu fumé du cannabis
et qui circulait à contresens tous feux
éteints sur l'autoroute
son fils est mort sur le coup sa fille
est handicapée à vie depuis il vient
tous les jours embrasser anne-sophie
avant d'aller travailler
regardez
après jc après on essaie de se
reconstruire mais vous avez passé le
samedi va lancer à l'eau c'est hier dans
mon fils à prévoir entre sophie ici
on peut peut-être une forme m rayonner
ou quelque chose comme ça on essaie de
se battre tous les jours sur france
permis à toulouse de toute façon
si les ai tous les jours avec des
joueurs savaient très bien puis le
journal mois
pion qui on pleure et puis voilà
boisé reprendre le volant avec de la
colle dans le sens où on ayant fumé du
la résine de cannabis voilà à quoi sa
commune et
on se rend pas compte on se rend pas
compte d'eux on voit l'impact au moment
de l'accident surtout aux infos on cible
assez dramatique on oublie vite et on
s'en rend pas compte que les gens vivent
ça pendant des années et des années de
l'année c'est dramatique et qu' il ya un
petit garçon de 7 ans qu'est parti qui
était en pleine forme une petite fille
qui avait 11 ans quand même 14
maintenant qu'ils entrent en 6e et puis
voilà
je lis je laime salem bien
et puis je sais pas ce que je vais
apprendre des choses sur mon boulot des
fonds en parlerons ensemble
lorsque je vais raconter des bêtises
qu'elle faisait que sa soeur alors ça on
va coller du souvenir parce que quoi je
parle des bêtises case avec sa soeur
excentive
éclate de rire et bien à propos elle
rigole bien à propos
entre toujours matière à discuter
peut-être qu'un jour elle veut dire oui
papa jeu pourtant tu demandes à chaque
fois
ça viendra peut-être
comme tout
c'est pour éviter des drames comme celui
d'anne sophie que l'alcoolémie au volant
est de plus en plus contrôlé il est 4
heures du matin amir
7000 le major lavalard et ses hommes
sont postés à la sortie d'une
discothèque
ils ont bloqué tous les accès impossible
d'échapper à l'alcootest
c'est bien beau war et pour l'instant
les conduites sont exemplaires
et quand vous allez en boîte comme ça
jusqu'à 4 heures du matin c'est ce que
vous aviez dit que vous voulez juste un
petit là
jamais quand je prends pour moi c'est la
peur du gendarme au sénat non non c'est
juste un besoin de sécurité j'ai déjà
mon accident j'ai pas envie d'en voir un
dixième des gens sérieux ouais
c'est bon pour moi on a besoin de lui
aussi un bon courage voilà le cas
typique c'est quelqu'un qui n'a pas bu
c'est pas son véhicule et c'est lui qui
conduit pour entraîne ça c'est quelque
chose que vous marquez de plus en plus
oui tout à fait c'est quelque chose qui
est de plus en plus courant la
conscience est pris par les jeunes de
qui conduit ne boit pas et je pense que
là c'est des points qu'on a remarqué
depuis quelques temps phénomène de plus
en plus important
autre phénomène nouveau de plus en plus
de parents comme ce père de famille
viennent en pleine nuit chercher leurs
enfants
m me chercher recherchez vos troupes
donc
vous avez partie du véhicule quand même
alors donc vous n'avez pas consommer
d'alcool monsieur bon c'est bien alors
vous faites le bus pour les y rechercher
et à quel endroit froid vous venez de
roi nous le leur allez bonne soirée
bonne route
mais plus la nuit avance et plus les
taux montent
0,15 euros quand
vous êtes limitant 0,25 un maximum route
à dire je devais sortir
a les yeux monsieur
avait d'accord
donc la limite c'est 0,25 à l'éthylotest
donc là il t'a 0,15 en dessous du seuil
légal
malgré tout une phobie fonsomme parce
que là le prochain verts et les hors jeu
pour d'autres c'est même le carton rouge
le même 0,6 il ya des jours où je vous
montre ne seront pas tous mauvais
jeu
donc là vous attendez ligne sur jeux
explique comment vous êtes en délire
l'ujf chose je suis pas dangereux
[Musique]
j'ai fait en version
6 heures du matin c'est l'heure de la
fermeture de la boîte de nuit et les
derniers fêtards tente d'échapper aux
contrôles ça fait demi tour ça fait demi
tour et ça s'arrête là bas
[Applaudissements]
c'est incroyable
ça fait demi-tour là parce qu'il nous
voilà ici ça fait demi tour il a même
inquiété pas monter dans leur voiture
malgré les nombreuses campagnes de
prévention la plupart des conducteurs ne
connaissent toujours pas les taux
autorisés
[Applaudissements]
ras
merci n'accepte avant cela appartement
sais tu connais pas dépasser les
atteintes 0,25 à
0,50 à cette époque pas ça vous fait
investisseurs
au même moment le major lavalard tente
de raisonner un groupe de jeunes le
conducteur a lui aussi largement dépassé
le taux légal d'alcoolémie
comprenez nous on voit en discothèque
vous êtes très bien quand vous
ça fait pour vous coucher
la limite aléatoire
je vous assure on a fait deux ou trois
verges est
là mais je vais pas nier je vous lynch
ses chevaux mais franchement
on est à combien la sur le taux de 0 59
alors que c'est 0 25 donc il est
largement au dessus de la limite
autorisée
et
il en est conscient par aman et rire est
parfaitement conscient et reconnaît
naturellement que il a consommé au cours
de la soirée une bouteille de whisky
et naturellement sur les sur les quatre
il est le seul à avoir un permis de
conduire ce qui fait comme il dit il est
obligé de première année ses camarades
ils sont frères donc ça ça fait encore
un comportement ça qu'on ne veut plus
accepter ce comportement là il faut le
bannir
et pour changer les comportements sur la
route l'association laser organise dans
l'essonne des journées exceptionnelles
notamment auprès des motards
aujourd'hui ils sont une trentaine à
participer volontairement à cette
opération qui répond au lourd bilan des
accidents de moto enregistré encore
l'année dernière donc à moto on est peu
visible
on est fragile
deux chiffres qui ont marqué que c'est
david jousse un spécialiste en
prévention routière qui encadre cette
journée le trafic moto en france arte
présente dans les motos représente 0 8%
du trafic et 13,7 pour cent des victimes
donc c'est pas un pour cent du trafic et
ses 13 27% des victimes
c'est aussi pour ça qu'on est là
aujourd'hui le but il est pas se lancer
la pierre à qui que ce soit il est de se
dire il ya peut-être des comportements
pour améliorer les choses et qu'on
puisse partager la route donc c'est ans
et il est 9 heures et la journée
commence par l'analyse d'un accident en
présence des gendarmes de l'essonne se
rendre compte réellement des
circonstances de l'accident c'était il y
a deux ans sur cette ligne droite ce
jour-là une moto percute de plein fouet
une voiture qui s'engagent sur ce par
conséquent ce matériel elles sont
dommageables bien sûr pour les deux
véhicules mais corporelle qui sont
nettement plus importantes dirais c'est
la mort du pilote de la motocyclette et
le fils qui se trouvait à l'arrière et
blessé grièvement dirais c'est une
fraction de seconde malheureusement on
regarde pas les véhicules qui arrivent
en face on fait pas attention pense à
autre chose et c'est vrai que là ces
comportements là sont malheureusement
très nombreux mais il faut garder la
maîtrise de son engin et en toutes
circonstances et en tous lieux sûrs on
peut aussi rajouter une chose c'est que
40% des motards se tuent tout seul sans
l'intervention d'un tiers c'est ce qu'on
avait vu sur un précédent incident à
côté d'ici
ça se passe très très bien fraîchement
santé concernés par ce qui vient d'être
dit est ce que c'est les choses qui vous
touchez pas tout à fait
vrai sinon c'est intéressant d'avoir le
point de vue des professionnels
ne s'est pas de voir un accident indien
en moto qui n'empêche pas de faire de la
moto qui m'arrêtera
et mais bon c'est vrai que ça met une
claque tout et
ça nous fait regarder quoi qu'il arrive
et puis en face on sait que c'est comme
ça on sait que on sait que tous les
motards bons ballons quant aux chances
d'avoir un accident si je pense que tout
le monde le français bon ça nous fait
pas peur je pense à six voir huit ans
mais après
à quelques kilomètres de là les motards
ont rendez vous sur ce site de
perfectionnement pour robert trottin le
président de l'association laser c'est
l'inexpérience qui est le plus souvent à
l'origine des comportements dangereux
les motards novices pour une bonne
formation moto école mais n'ont pas
forcément vécu les différentes
situations et donc l'accélérateur
d'expérience c'est ce défi qui fait que
en 24 heures il faut qu'ils acquièrent
le bagage nécessaire pour être un vrai
motards expérimentés
premier exercice avec les pompiers de
l'essonne apprendre à manier sa moto
avec l'épreuve de l'eponge un bon test
pour l' équilibre
[Applaudissements]
et ça ce sont des exercices simples de
maniabilité pour rechercher l'osmose
avec la monture et connect limite du
véhicule et surtout les siennes et on
devrait tous avoir faire ça sans
problème
deuxième exercice l'un des plus délicats
pour les motards le freinage
ok
et oui offert de charme
et s'y faire super les exercices
vraiment hein ça remet en condition on
met dans le bain le coût des freinages
c'était plutôt sympa parce que on s'est
rendu compte qu'il y avait encore un peu
de marge que c'était pas beau ça très
bien parce que comme je suis passagère
je pense que c'est bien que les les
conducteurs se remémore un peu ce qu'ils
ont appris il ya quelques années tu pas
faut être conscient du danger puis faire
de dire oui c'est vraiment il est
conscient du danger on n'est pas
toujours conscients parce que parce
qu'on est des fois des vitesses qui sont
on est complètement inconscient dans mon
choix est clair
il n'ya pas sûr que les machines qui
alla non non non je sais bien
puissante c'est la moitié il a les trois
quarts des gens qui sont là en clair
qu'on a envie c'est de là qu'on a
tendance à rouler
celle là il est 14 heures et tout le
monde se prépare pour le parcours de
l'après midi au programme une centaine
de kilomètres sur petit deux roues
ça permet d'enchaîner différentes
allures avec différents environnements
ce que la vitesse grâce adapté pas
uniquement en fonction de la limitation
de l'inventaire mais il ya des endroits
où seront autorisés dans la 70 voire 90
mais si c'est mouillé en glissant sous
bois avec un virage assez dangereux for
all est bien en dessous drac donc c'est
pour voir leur capacité d'adaptation en
fonction de l'environnement
david monte à l'arrière d'une moto et
ferme la marche pendant plus de deux
heures il va juger le comportement et la
dure du groupe
les voitures la pluie un mauvais
revêtement pour le motard de danger est
partout
leur brutale à elle a l'air sympa comme
ça va être une de pierre et j'ai un
moment bien grasses sur les côtés et
feuilles mortes et relève et la route et
pas large à cet endroit là avec une
rafale de vent dès qu'on est con sortie
soit on est sur le côté gras soit on se
retrouve voie de gauche alors pas de
voiture en face à sara une voiture en
face ça va plus
une heure plus tard pas d'incident de
parcours c'est l'heure du débriefing
qu'est ce qui vous a plu quels sont les
sujets qu'il faudrait plus développés
quelles sont les choses qui vous ont
paru peut-être moins intéressante mais
passer mon permis à trois ans j'avais
l'impression d'avoir encore tout frais
dans la tête dans les jambes dans les
bras et en fait on s'aperçoit que tous
aient tous ces beaux souvenirs là
physiquement on les a un petit peu
perdues si j'ai eu mon cas mais il y a
trois ans donc je croyais encore
connaître pas mal de choses et puis on
se rend compte qu'on oublie vite car
j'ai le comportement comme ça je ne
sais pas je sais pas oui on a oui et
puis qui m'ont je pense que on est quand
même fort pas défendu de là où
ouais je pense que c'est ma vision des
mises à niveau que david mène
régulièrement dans toute la france sinon
participants quand ils sortent se soit
rendu compte que la sécurité routière
s'était aussi du plaisir on pouvait
réfléchir sur soi même avoir de
l'information se rendent compte et donc
se dire tiens je me suis rendu compte là
j'avais pas la capacité ou
gagner l'humilité quand ils prennent la
route ils peuvent plus dire je ne savais
pas à ça c'est quelque chose pour moi de
gagner
le lendemain à 800 km de là dans un
autre département l'association mène à
un autre combat auprès des seniors de la
route cette fois
sur ce parking ils sont une vingtaine à
participer à ce stage de
perfectionnement avec au programme de la
matinée des exercices de maniabilité et
de freinage d'urgence
si j'habitais un gamin là vous vous
seriez arrêté probablement quelque chose
on peut le conduire vers venir pas de
limites
le l'âge est une notion abstraite
certaines personnes sont en pleine forme
à 70 à 75 ans et d'autres sont vraiment
fatiguées 65 ans
[Applaudissements]
ouais à
[Musique]
et bien c'est à la fois ça a été
dynamique les rapides au départ et le
freinage sans bloquer les roues a été de
bonne qualité donc là c'est tout à fait
correct vous avez vous avez le permis
depuis quand même temps environ
1943 1943 voilà ça fait 61 62 ans n'a pu
j'ai tué personne je suis
allé
regardez dans les feux de stop et vous
pourrez
77 ans marcel participent activement et
pour la deuxième fois à ce stage pour
les seniors de la route c'est pas
direction assistée
[Musique]
que les livres les bassines terminer ma
54 9 septembre 1954
simple 150 francs
il n'y avait pas d'auto école à l'époque
je ne fis ça démarrait pas encore
pour marcel c'est la deuxième tentative
de freinage
[Musique]
il faut s'arrêter à l âge est écrasée
c'est bon là vous me roule dessus face à
l'éternel s'arrêter le démarrage était
très bien efficace le bantam que j'ai de
bons réflexes
je continue mais le jour où j'en aurai
plus et ben j'arrêterai la voiture parce
que je suis contre le fait qu'on laisse
le permis de conduire à vie ça je suis
contre contre contre de dire parce que
il faut reconnaître qu'à une certaine
période de sa vie on n'a plus les mêmes
réflexes on a plus
moi je trouve que on doit arrêter quand
il faut
la france est pourtant l'un des rares
pays européens à accorder le permis de
conduire à vie quel que soit l'âge aucun
contrôle médical aucune remise à niveau
ne sont obligatoires les seniors ne sont
pas dangereux n'est pas une population
de conducteurs ou deux conductrices qui
est préoccupante par rapport à la
sécurité routière la france le pays
d'europe occidentale sont des sociétés
où naît un senior toutes les 90 secondes
toutes les 90 secondes il ya une
personne de plus de 60 ans qui arrive
est dès lors en pourcentage on va avoir
une population d'automobilistes qui sera
particulièrement âgées mais ce n'est pas
pour autant qu'ils seront plus dangereux
par contre c'est parce qu'ils sont âgés
qu'il faut des cessions comme
aujourd'hui d'actualisation des
connaissances des comportements
l'après midi l'association a demandé à
des moniteurs d'auto école de juger
cette fois la conduite sur route des
seniors honneur agents 92 ans le doyen
du groupe ces normes et de clientèle
s'est pas l'écrit l'auteur sait être
réglé vos rétroviseurs c'est ce que
j'allais dire c'est important à l'heure
et revient on va le voir tout au long de
la deûle audit pour que vous fassiez une
bonne conduite et puis après vous avez
les deux rétroviseurs extérieurs alors
les vôtres c'est ceux qui sont en bas
vous voyez les plus gros seins
iphone sur le rond-point la sortie
premier test l'engagement dans un rond
point en direction de l'autoroute
doucement à caen vous freinez
voilà et vous sortirez à l'autoroute
regardez il ya le panneau bleu à vous le
voyez et quand vous rentrez dans le rond
point ne vous placez pas en plein milieu
essayer de choisir correctement votre
voix et de vous y tenir
c'est dommage que pendant toute la vie
d'un conducteur il puisse pas avoir par
exemple ça a été actée pendant un moment
par les pouvoirs publics le fait
d'imaginer que tous les dix ans le
conducteur puisse revenir et c'est le
c'est le minimum parce que ça enlève les
mauvaises habitudes et surtout ça permet
un recyclage oui jean j'ai connu une
époque on n'était même pas ni ne n'étais
même pas munis de feux stop
voilà imaginez un peu l'évolution qui a
pu avoir aujourd'hui
deuxième test les distances de sécurité
genre puisqu'on est dans une situation
de conduite là
on est à peu près à 70 km heure
regardez devant jean moi je vous l'a dit
il a habité à 70 ça va assez limité à 70
ans maximum gamma knife au palais au
delà mais est-ce que vous pensez que la
distance de sécurité entre les deux
véhicules entre lui et nous du coup
pensé que c'est suffisant
largement et champ vous mettre très
sympathique mais j'ai apprécié au cloud
est persuadé que vous allez arriver
arrêter la voiture dans toutes les
situations
roulant
sera entendue c'est toujours pas on
n'est pas sur un formule 1 on n'est pas
sur un circuit et on n'a pas la
compétence du pilote de la formule 1
rappelez vous ce que je viens de vous
dire le pire des ennemis pour un
conducteur c'est de penser qu'il est
capable de tout faire avec sa voiture
vue on est collé aux camions a laissé
lui de la distance
vite ça fait rien laisser à distance
serait pas pressé
vous êtes têtu quand même
on va se remettre à la même place
et puis
voilà faites moi plaisir parce que vous
m fort sympathique je voudrais pas qu'il
vous arrive que ce soit un accident que
ce soit même un seul accrochage parce
que la voiture j'ai l'impression pour
vous c'est du plaisir il faut que ça le
reste donc n'hésitez pas à retourner
voir une auto école si dans votre
quartier et l'auto-école n'hésitez pas
allez la voir sincèrement mettez à
profit ce qu'on a vus ensemble
[Musique]
parfois vous avez envie de retirer le
permis est certain
c'est vrai que suivant les situations se
dit on se dit est que il faudrait qu'ils
ne prennent plus la voiture on a eu des
exemples rare mais on a eu des exemples
moi je me rappelle dans le var en
préfecture où il ya des enfants des fois
qu'ils viennent en me disant je voudrais
que ma mère ou mon père
puisse plus conduire et les gendarmes
souvent disent à juste titre je pense
que ils ont pas de possibilité de il
faut malheureusement qui cause ou un
accident vrai véritablement une
infraction lourde pour qu'on lui retire
on leur retire pardon ce droit
alors pour que les seniors profite de ce
droit le plus longtemps possible ici on
les forme pour leur sécurité mais
surtout pour celles des autres
autant d'être ici bien sûr qu'on apprend
des choses qui est tout de même nous
échappe un peu maintenant on a pris nos
limites
c'est à dire jury maintenant aujourd'hui
pas de bêtes mourinho mais je vais trop
tard alors ceux qui sont derrière ils
n'ont pas vu
sont pas renseignés sur mais attention
je parle que arrivé à un certain âge on
devrait obliger tend à nous faire
remettre en question au moins au moins
le code de la route
non j'étais obligé de repasser le permis
il doit percer mais donnant à penser
les résumés mais d'abord les salles que
réactualisation j'étais genre il être
ici aujourd'hui
à la prochaine je serai encore plus
heureux à la prochaine
retour un hôpital st maurice ici on
tente d'oublier l'accident pour mieux se
reconstruire
comme une carte normalement il ya moyen
de trouver sans deviner
pourquoi 4 il est 10 heures du matin
ashley termine son cours d'orthophonie
tient parce que tu parles le nom à ce
que tu peux me donner la date s'il te
plaît pour j'écrive quand même la date
vendredi
non jeudi 17
février 2005 qu'il
est ce que tu pourrais me plais
rapidement
et plus rapidement la date
jeudi21
eux a annoncé
cette
incertain j
angers7
en
vfr
2 005 super merci c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui quand ashley s'est fait
renversé il ya six mois elle était en
cinquième depuis elle rêve de rentrer
chez elle et de reprendre l'école
3ieme pas connaître
ça m'empêche de réfléchir à plein show
tu as l'impression d'être différente
d'avant l'accident non et je suis paré
colak vous que avant mon accident et je
comprends pas pourquoi ils veulent pas
me laisser sortir je comprends pas c'est
d'écouter parler là je pense que tu sais
pourquoi tu peux analyser pourquoi tu as
besoin de rester encore un petit peu
parce que j'ai besoin de rééducation
voilà surtout travailler certaines
choses à les apprentissages scolaires
la mémoire
même s'il te fait d'énormes progrès
depuis quelques semaines qui ont encore
besoin beaucoup de travail et
d'oubli par exemple quand tu vas gagner
dans nos points du temps quelques
minutes après tu peux avoir oublié ce
que tu avais un ou si tu te déplaces
d'un endroit à un autre du service et
bien malgré tout tu perds le il de ce
que tu devais faire au moment où tu te
déplaces un tueur dans ta chambre ben tu
as oublié tu devais aller à l'école et
non pas dans ta chambre par exemple
mais avant c'était avant maintenant on
voit qu'elle quand même des difficultés
au niveau scolaire je serais pas parti
chez ma copine je n'ai pas eu cet
accident
je t'en veux
tu penses que c'est ta faute
ici chaque minute est mise à profit et
au détour d'un couloir les médecins en
profitent souvent pour tester les
progrès de leurs petits patients
puisque elle t'a fait deviner et s y
trouvaient et tu sais encore ce que l'on
sait poche
rappelle un peu quand même elle essaye
[Musique]
un push à
niveau à l'hôpital st maurice certains
enfants viennent même en consultation
dix ans après l'accident
c'est le cas de reynald il a passé de
longs mois ici en rééducation lorsqu'il
était bébé
depuis il revient régulièrement dans le
service pour voir le docteur anne
laurent vanille
on était en province comme c'est indiqué
dans la famille on était partis
d'affaires ne peut découvrir les enfants
la famille qui avait dit vous dis moi à
l'époque on n'avait pas encore eu
l'occasion d'y aller
et en fait ce jour là il pleuvait
beaucoup et dans un virage on a croisé
un semi remorque un camion à 38 ans qui
a perdu le contrôle de son véhicule qui
s'est mis en portefeuille qui nous à
fouetter et envoyé dans le champ d'à
côté ça s'est passé en une seconde
évidemment
et tout de suite il y avait une petite
maison à côté on entend des gens
n'attendent a sorti les enfants de du
véhicule on était un petit peu sur le
toit on s'est tout de suite aperçu qu'il
était blessé ses deux frères aussi été
blessé mais c'était plus superficiel en
fait il avait eu que des petits éclats
de verre au visage et puis dans dans le
mouvement ne s'est pas vraiment rendu
compte mais on s'est tout de suite rendu
compte que c'était grave pour reynald
moi j'ai du mal à en parler
oui ouais c'est dingue profonde quoi
un bébé dans derrière
j'ai l'oeuf j'ai quand même le miroir
ses frères ses miroirs quoi donc jeu
j'arrive à le projeter comme ils
auraient dû l'être quoi
raynal de revient au centre une fois par
an anne laurent vanier son équipe
effectue un bilan complet pour connaître
ses progrès ou les difficultés qu'ils
rencontrent est ce que tu sais où est ta
main droite
les blattes à ma droite
c'est laquelle celle là d'accord super
et ma main droite à moi c'est là qu'elle
sait laquelle ma main droite
sais
tu te demandes si je te tient autant à
kiev voilà ma droite où elle à ma main
droite à moi
montre là moi
très bien
continue
est ce que tu sais combien ça fait par
exemple quatre russes 6
istres qui te ment et c'est très bien
combien ça fait 8 mois 3
8 mois 3
je suis pas alors imagine que tu es tu à
huit bombes on est moi je n'en mange
trois combien skate en reste
et c'est pas bon
l'enfant qu'est ce que c'est c'est
quelques acquis mon corps et nal par
exemple au moment de l'accident il avait
dix mois alors même si c'était un bébé
très performant à dis-moi dis-moi on a
quand même pas beaucoup d'acquis donc ça
veut dire qu'à aux conséquences
immédiates de l'accident vont s'ajouter
possiblement et même très probablement
quand il s'agit des traumas crâniens
graves des conséquences à distance avec
un des effets à retardement
parce que les apprentissages ne vont pas
se faire comme il se devrait donc le
décalage va s'accentuer même par rapport
à la norme jusqu'aux trois ans comme ils
ont patron besoins scolaires n'ya rien
eh ben ça allait je me suis pas trop
aperçu et puis au moins la scolarisation
là ça a été plus dur il décalage on l'a
ressenti tout de suite et iliad redoublé
sa dernière année de maternelle et life
et l'intégration au sénat alors que ses
frères son temps c'est un an déjà
allé lesur et mad
au revoir au revoir
au revoir
bonne journée
ces enfants en permanence arrivée dans
votre service quel sentiment
de gâchis et un peu de colère de colère
parce que je crois que ne se rend pas
compte quand on va un peu trop vite ou
quand on brûle un feu rouge on se rend
pas compte de ce que ça peut les
conséquences puis après ça c'est en une
fraction de seconde et après c'est trop
tard et que vous aviez que la presse
pour la vie entière pour retrouver un
jour peut être sa vie d'avant ashley
elle a encore un long chemin une attente
qui a 14 ans lui semble interminable
salle avenue qui passe accroît
j'espère que je vais sortir d'ici
imagine oublié ici ne plus jamais
revenir ici mais je sais que je vais
revenir ici pour des petits trucs si je
sors les si
elles n'ont plus tard juste à le faire
merci pour trois jours toujours
je me vois déjà dans son camp des voix
moi je me rêve tout le temps je rêve
tout le temps d'un ancien coach de faire
quoi nous laisse tout le temps j'aurais
pourtant
quelques kilomètres heure de trop un
coup de fil au volant pour beaucoup
d'entre nous ce sont encore des réflexes
sans grande conséquence mais pour ces
enfants qui à ce moment-là on traversait
une rue où l'achat une main ce sont des
années d'efforts et de souffrance
[Musique]
alors pour éviter ces blessures
d'enfants à belfort le lieutenant
camille delonca sensibilise les
conducteurs de demain aux violences
routières
pour la première fois elle accompagne un
groupe de lycéens dans ce centre de
rééducation
ce matin ils sont une vingtaine d'élèves
a rencontré des victimes de la route
en deux ans on part minimum de 3 gens de
passage ici dans les meilleurs des cas
parce que les élèves vont voir ça va pas
être facile
la visite commence par la chambre de
marie-jo accidenté il ya presque deux
ans
oui mais ça va pas trop mal votre
surprise non non on avait été prévenu
donc un peu moi je suis resté à moi en
réanimation j'étais un peu plus de deux
semaines dans le coma
donc tout votre corps ne bouge pas il
faut qu'après on perd très très vite la
masse musculaire et il faut vous
récupérez le choc ça fait longtemps que
vous êtes ici au centre au centre ça
fait treize mois
nous disons que je me dis ça évolue
alors c'est déjà pas mal
chaque jour c'est un petit peu de gagner
un
la
base c'est que s'ils bougent pas
est-ce que c'est lourd en fait le fait
que l'agent ne bouge pas comme vous l'a
supporté à ce que c'est lourd de la
porter à oui c'est énorme c'est
phénoménal comme ça peut peser lourd une
jambe qui bouge pas ah oui c'est très
très lourd et il faut des fois pas la
bouche et de beaucoup mais elle m'a
impressionné sûr que ça pèse une tonne
[Musique]
dans la chambre d'à côté nicolas est un
ancien motard
[Musique]
voilà maintenant rejoint après la
rencontre le malaise est réel manu
[Musique]
alors
impressionnant
pression
il a avalé tout groupe là vous avez quel
âge moi j'avais 12 ans et il est mon
accident notamment je fais de la moto et
je t'aimerai sa place je me dis qu'est
ce que vous dites là dans la tête alors
que ça pourrait être n'importe qui
surtout que moi je fais de la moto donc
si je pourrais te remettre à sa place
dans les consciences compteur mais le
pire
a été accidentée il ya trois semaines en
sortie côté
sorties de boîtes de nuit j'avais pas
dormi la veille je me suis endormi au
volant j'ai pas senti le coup venir j'ai
je suis rentré dans une murette
j'avoue tout sorti avec une fracture au
sternum le conte de fées des mais
j'aurais pu rester quoi
j'ai relativisé la tuque une semaine
dure une semaine coucher sont bougés
donc
après ça je suis content que dans l'état
où je suis par rapport à certaines
personnes qui est
sur leur éducation
il est midi et les lycéens continuent
leur visite le dialogue se poursuit dans
cette salle avec une dizaine de blessés
comme marc en fauteuil roulant depuis
son accident
au départ ouvre moto je roulais
tranquillement sur ma voix bien un gars
qui est venu en facilement il m'a coincé
la moto qui j'ai fait un petit vol plané
sur une vingtaine de mètres
j'ai 23 ans de moto derrière moi j'étais
jamais tomber puis vint la première
chute ça a été la bonne depuis deux ans
camille delonca travail avec ces jeunes
lycéens sur l'insécurité routière ils
ont préparé toute une campagne de
prévention et viennent soumettre leur
projet à ces grands blessés
avec donc une image à une illustration
et un slogan pour justement faire passer
un message
convenable
savez je trouve que les images elles
sont encore pas assez choquant quoi
parce que les gens ils réagissent pas
assez
donc eu l'accident c'est une chose mais
on cause pas à céder des conséquences
après quoi ce que les gens y voit l
accident il voit les images mais on voit
pas bien la peine des gens seraient du
quai où et comment ils souffrent comment
je trouve qu'il n'ya pas assez de choses
là dessus
si on est là aujourd'hui c'est pour que
vous preniez bien conscience vous même
de ces problèmes là et que vous puissiez
ensuite expliqué aux autres jeunes
puisque je pense que vous vous avez
perçu ce qu'on veut vous faire passer ce
que ce qu'ils veulent vous dire je pense
que vous avez perçu à savoir l'instant
c'est bien mais et après bien on pas
très bon voire à nos amis et on espère
là on est loin du policier qui
déambulent dans les rues avec sa souche
de contraventions là ça dépasse le cadre
du différend d'une part j'en fais un
combat personnel et puis d'autre part je
vous avoue que je préfère faire ça parce
que
quand on en arrive à mettre des
contraventions c'est que c'est une forme
d'échec quelque part non je préfère
prévenir que guérir l'adage est bien
valable mais
oui oui non oui je suis loin de mon
travail de policier non parce que dans
mon travail de policier il ya la notion
de protection de la personne et c'est ce
que je fais je protège les personnes en
intervenant avant que l'incident ait
lieu
faire encore et toujours baisser les
chiffres sauver des vies
réparer celle que la violence routière a
brisé pour tous ceux qui chaque jour
combattent l'inconscience ou plus
simplement l'inattention volant la route
est encore longue
[Musique]
oh